Peter Brown Mike Alma Hardy we are
playing God of War on ps4 from Sony
Santa Monica the next in the iconic
franchise but things are different this
time around
yeah you see this thing the Leviathan
acts by so your reviews up but in this
video we want to do a you know like more
specific combat breakdown because things
have changed this time around you'll
probably notice right off the bat and
you've probably already noticed in a lot
of trailers you've been paying attention
that oh there's a tray us your son hey
buddy with his bow and arrow yeah he is
a helpful little guy in combat and in
addition to managing you know my
standard AXA tax yeah things like this
some magical abilities and stuff I can
also command him to fire his bone arrow
yeah on enemies and open them up for
combos from Kratos so as you'll notice
you've there's the over-the-shoulder
camera it's more of a you know like
maybe no it's not character action game
like the older games were or Devil May
Cry it is kind of more along the lines
of a melee renze before or last of us
Tomb Raider maybe in terms of level
design and stuff but it's also kind of
remembered if you played hell blade at
all last year you might have a sense of
how this plays but this goes much more
in depth the combos that you know and
love from God of War are still here
presented a little different dish yeah
it's like the same sort of flow yeah to
putting in combos let's give them a
little demonstration with it yeah he's
got some trogir here which are
reincarnated norse warriors yeah so you
got a shield best you can use there you
notice your shield folds up into your
arm so that's one skill tree we'll show
those in a little bit but right now that
was a runic attack which is kind of your
magic pack you can see down the bottom
left it sound cool down now
sorry my say foul didn't start you're
the most health no it did not but I
think I'll be okay mm-hmm
I think got a got a bit of a fight
coming up here that's true is there
anything else left in this room any
health I may have missed sometimes there
are pots so if you see on the left side
it won't do a lot but on the left on
your UI down on the bottom left yeah
that is a talisman that you equip and we
you just did a health / stat essentially
gave you a bit of help for a short time
yeah so why don't you describe what I
look for some to help oh here we go
nice actually maybe no description
necessary well what do you say do I dive
in do I look for one more I look for one
more maybe I think that I don't think
there's anything in this one oddly
enough so you have 2x throws also
there's one that you can you can track
multiple people before you release it
and then there's another that's just a
more powerful vertical throw I don't
know if I have much choice here I say we
just can't dive right in and we will do
my best not to embarrass all of gamespot
in this video so before you fight him
you could show the trees maybe there you
go Kizer that's a truck neutral so we
don't want to show all these trees
because we don't want to spoil any too
much the experience at all for people
this video being out about a week before
the game's international release but
this is where you're upgrading your ax
shield bow and unarmed combat
if you throw your ax or just on equip
your axe kratos just flat-out punches
people very hard yeah and he's got a lot
of skills so you know it is a I wouldn't
say it's a critical piece of combat but
it's certainly an excellent opportunity
to explore the many different like
tactical you know advantages you could
have sure in battle it's actually
surprisingly a lot of ways to fight in
this game yes we saw you using the
shield bash which pretty much makes a
enemy a shielded enemy kind of like drop
their guard and then you've got here you
can do actual attack that hits multiple
enemies at time a OE kind of things and
then if you go over to the bow and arrow
you can actually upgrade at Reyes which
I've been doing a lot in my playthrough
because he's very helpful yeah you'll
see over here on the left that magical
combat will be a thing that comes around
which I'll be honest Phil it's a little
bit of P to me but that also means it's
incredibly useful and this game has no
shortage of challenges if you look for
them pretty much everything here can be
used to your advantage
at some point or another so now we got
this troll I'm certainly do so at Reyes
I'll let you fight him while we talk
about at Reyes what's his name Doughty
Hammar so this is a I don't know what
maybe like a sixth into the game if that
even maybe not even that because this
game can be quite long if you're doing
everything there is you see you're
actually commanding at Reyes to shoot
those arrows with square
there's your spartan spartan rage which
people might recognize from the older
games yep
Kratos he gets mad who knew I'm gonna do
a ground pound with r2 but well he just
did yeah
and you got your skill cool down to the
bottom left which people see I'm taking
a very cautious approach yeah this fight
because I don't want to die while we're
doing this yes but yeah getting bin and
clothes is very important when you're on
fire
oh I tend yeah OOP go now at Reyes is
yelling about a healing stone sometimes
he can actually unearth those in combat
why am I on fire I thought I was
avoiding that yeah do it at all so
that's another runic attack right there
so you've almost got your talisman back
that you can refill health with it won't
do a ton but it might help a little bit
for sure and you seem like dodging is a
very important thing here sure that can
make or break you during a fight if
you're somehow you know ill-equipped for
battle yes there you go
now sometimes because equipment is a big
thing in this game you can really tailor
it to favor different aspects of Kratos
or you know maybe account for some
weaknesses he has yeah if you find
yourself maybe not prepared for a fight
the way you want it to be you can
generally still survive and win there's
almost no requirements in terms of where
Kratos is as a character and while you
were talking Trey us just did find you a
health stone oh thanks so that is one
specific tunic that he has essentially
armor I don't maybe we can dive into
that in this video after this fight so
so that just happened yeah I can get
difficult we we don't like I said we
don't wanna show too much there's so
you could spoil this game because
there's a lot of time packed but yeah a
lot of this game as opposed to in the
old games when you would just you know
open chests for blood and then spend
that on combos this is much more about
Armour items and equipment maybe those
things disguised as gear and whatnot
there you go you got full health now all
right I don't extend this is that you
have to fail thank you and so this is a
one of many different types of enemies
you'll fight I don't know if you can
talk too much while you're fighting but
so the opening is obviously kind of
really popularized those QuickTime
events during cutscenes what's the deal
with those here there there are like
some light QuickTime event applications
but honestly it's not a huge part of the
game it's definitely been you know when
you compare it to like the the
multi-layered QuickTime event like set
pieces those are kind of different a lot
of times in combat it's just like the
final move and you really only have to
do like one or two button presses sure
they're much more to me I'm a fair deal
in the game they feel less like
Interactive cutscenes they feel more
like you know like it'll say like press
r1 or lr2 to attack and Kratos you'll
just start beating on them and it'll
feel like you still have a little more
agency than you might have in those
other cases that's true yeah there are
some like mid fight sequences where you
get to bash an enemy a little actually
if can you do can you shoot him with a
tray us a few times if people are paying
attention there is a smaller bar under
Doughty Hammar as health bar which is
the stun generator right which is pretty
big
they tell you early on the game a viable
way to kill or really hurt some enemies
is to fully stun them so if you fill
that bar up arrows can do it certain
arrows do it better but also Kratos has
punching attacks do them better than his
axe if you fill that up you'll see an r3
prompt if you have the UI turned on or
the HUD turned on you'll see an r3
prompt next to the enemy and that
triggers what we're kind of talking
about these takedowns of sorts they're
not all that varied but like each
individual enemy has unique ones I'd say
yeah you got your shield recharge as you
want
good dotting thank you
and this dude is tougher than most
trolls you'd fight up until now again
this is like a I don't even know also
I've been playing this game with an
upgraded crate us for a few days now so
I definitely know some good things yeah
but like again it goes back to that what
I was saying earlier is that you don't
need very specific abilities to take
down a boss they give you an advantage
but really it's just about you know your
attentiveness and your reactions yes
there you go so here we got an example
of that so you filled up his stun meter
he's also closer to death
got a pretty gruesome kill on this dude
right here are ya you so you're actually
manually depressing art or that are one
there and then cleaving his face got a
cool finishing move yeah yeah trance
with his comments you get some loot okay
something just showed up that we weren't
really supposed to show I think yeah but
uh of course you'll see it when you play
this game about April 20th this will be
out for ps4 your review is up right now
you can watch that if you want to yes
please do actually and this has been you
know like a pretty cursory breakdown of
the combat as you soften the skill trees
and as you saw from Pete playing a few
different styles between the shield the
axe the Talon bow which at Reyes is
using and on armed combat and all the
you see different gear like this Kratos
might look very different from the one
that you were using cuz this is my early
save file yeah but he's got different
risks he's got different uh chests are
more waste armor you might notice that
they will start to look pretty cool
throughout they'll keep the actual
playthrough but they will also start
changing up your elemental effects and
status effects and resistances and even
combos in some source and rudik attacks
indeed there's a lot of time packaged
games a big game you can go check out
game spots review on youtube or on
gamespot.com of course and we will have
more from the game coming out in about a
week on April 20th that is when we will
have more features up whether it's
guides or kind of in-depth video essays
and we'll hope to see you then